the Concorde flew from the 1970s to the
early 2000s it was sleek sexy and
incredibly fast like Mach 2 fast which
was kind of a problem the Conchords
double sonic boom was so loud that the
world banned commercial supersonic
aircraft over land but now NASA is
researching a new supersonic commercial
plane design one that's supposed to be a
lot quieter the new explains design is
intended to keep pressure waves from
building up along the airframe and wing
surfaces enough to turn the volume of
the boom down from the Conchords to
throttling 106 decibels to a dull thud
like 65 or 70 decibels if it works
supersonic flights between New York and
LA could become a reality
cutting a 6-hour flight down to two and
a half maybe the first prototypes
supposed to fly in 2019 so yeah your
flights a little delayed